foreign
to you youngsters but there was a time
when Madonna was a pop culture
phenomenon she was a star who produced
Sensational chart-topping Smash Hits now
the songs weren't any good of course
they were there was never a time when
Madonna was was making good music but
she was relevant and she sang a lot
about sex and people said wow did you
hear that new Madonna song she sings
about sex again
that music critics said that it was
groundbreaking
because music critics have been calling
sexual songs groundbreaking for the past
55 years or so
but each generation has its own
revolutionary pop stars who sing about
sex Madonna was replaced by Britney
Spears and then Britney Spears went
insane and shaved their head and she was
replaced by Katy Perry and then Katy
Perry finished making her three songs
and she was replaced by somebody else
and then by somebody else and then
eventually cardi B came along and when
cardi B came along music critics were
astounded again they said my God this
one sings about sex in extra raunchy
ways this is the raunchiest we've heard
yet it's genius but then came lizzo and
critics exclaimed wow she sings about
sex and it's raunchy and she's obese and
they were smitten anew the point is that
Madonna's time came and went
she's now 64 years old which translates
to you know 6 400 years old in pop star
years she might as well have been born
in the early days of the Sumerian Empire
at this point and you might think then
that she would simply just uh take her
hundreds of millions of dollars Retreat
to a private island and and live out the
rest of her life in peace confident that
she has passed the whorishness torch to
a new generation of musical prostitutes
but Madonna has thrived on attention
she's lived off of it fed on it like a
vampire bat for decades she doesn't know
how to do anything else
and so Grandma emerges from her Mansion
every once in a while disfigured from
plastic surgery looking strikingly
similar to a 1990s Marilyn Manson
actually and she makes another bid for
the world's attention that's what led to
this Tick Tock video a few days ago
where she seems to come out of the
closet watch
[Music]
she looks like Marilyn Manson she does I
don't mean that as an insult well it's
hard to say that that's not an insult
but anyway so she she throws her panties
towards the garbage can and she misses
and this is her strange metaphorical way
of telling us that she's sexually
attracted to women of course she already
made she already she already kind of
made that announcement when she made out
with Britney Spears on stage at the VMAs
like two decades ago
so this is not exactly breaking news
if she was intending to be in the closet
this whole time and keep it a secret
then she must have been uh utilizing the
hide in plain sight strategy
but why not go back to the well and and
come out of the closet again this is a
tried and true tactic among celebrities
these days Demi Lovato has come out of
the closet seven different times as
seven different versions of gay and she
she just keeps on doing it everyone is
desperate to come out of the closet
these days even if they were never in
one to begin with
this week we had a national coming out
day which featured lots of uh similar
public declarations like this one from
somebody named Lee sharp he tweets
happy coming out day I am polyamorous
and in an organically formed Triad with
my two lovely Partners we also each in
various amounts date others as well just
as people can love more than one parent
or child or friend romantic love for
multiple people is valid too
well at least the Triad is organically
formed call me a purist but I prefer
organic Triads that's just what I prefer
sometimes I'll buy a few bundles of them
in the produce section at Wegmans keep
them in vases around the house they make
you know for nice decorations especially
because of the of the bright colored
hair now in their case the interesting
thing is that the guy
he looks like a relatively normal guy
like you should be working at Office
Depot or something except for the hair
which looks like it was dyed with food
coloring without his consent while he
was passed out the two women on the
other hand are going for the typical
Star Trek villain aesthetic
but the point is that
though I cannot much relate to the sort
of women that this guy's attracted to
he is still attracted to women he's in a
sexual relationship with women
we're at a point now where straight men
can come out of the closet as straight
men
and nobody questions it as long as their
hair is died in unnatural color
I could color mine green and come out of
the closet as a I could come out of the
closet as a man in a mono Amorous
relationship with one woman and as long
as I have the green hair I too would be
welcomed into the LGBT fold
well maybe not me specifically but most
people could do that
the LGBT initialism has been expanded
precisely to include every possible
sexual orientation that's how we end up
with labels like demisexual which
describes people who need to feel an
emotional connection to someone in order
to be sexually attracted to them
otherwise known as just like that's
women that's that's how women are
they're also gray sexuals those are
people who are sometimes sexually
attracted to other people and sometimes
not
so if you've ever been in a room and not
felt sexually attracted to somebody in
it
then you're gray sexual congratulations
you're you're LGBT
and then there are uh there are a
romantic people
which are those who not to be confused
with asexual aromantic those are people
who experience sexual attraction but
often have no romantic feelings or
attachments that go along with it so
they're they're sexual but they're not
they're not romantic
which according to almost any single
woman on the dating scene
describes almost every single man on the
dating scene
the LGBT community is is the only
oppressed victim group in human history
that people are desperate to be
associated with it's the only victim
group that people would pretend they are
a part of for the sake of social status
rather than pretending they're not a
part of for the sake of
self-preservation which is usually
historically how it goes with uh victim
groups
it holds this unique position among
historical victim groups because of
course
it is not a victim group at all quite
the contrary it is the group with the
highest cultural status the most social
capital and you always know what that
group is and uh the the saying is like
whatever group you're not allowed to
criticize that's the group with the uh
that's at the at the top of the
hierarchy and that's true with the LGBT
also
but another way of looking at this is
like what what is the group that people
are
clamoring to be in what's the club
everybody wants to be a part of
and that partly explains too the extreme
rocket-like rise in gender
non-conforming so-called identities as
the Daily Caller reports this week
Maryland's largest public school
district saw a 582 percent increase in
the number of students identifying as
gender non-conforming in just two years
according to internal data posted to an
Educator's Twitter page Montgomery
Public County Schools um Montgomery
County Public Schools gathered this data
from forms school counselors fill out
when students approach them to talk
about gender identity issues because the
numbers rely on self-reporting the near
Sevenfold increase from 2019 to 2022
could indicate a massive increase in the
number of gender diverse students an
environment that encourages those
students to be more open with counselors
or both during the 2019 to 2020 school
year a total of 35 students reported
gender non-conformity to a counselor
including four Elementary School
students 19 middle school students and
12 high schoolers during the 2021-2022
school year the total number of students
reporting gender non-conformity Spike to
239
including 18 Elementary School students
129 middle schoolers and 92 high
schoolers
so kids in school have gotten the
message
how could they not it's screamed at them
everywhere they turn
that being a normal straight person who
identifies as their own biological sex
is uncool and uninteresting
um and so they're trying to keep up with
the trend as kids always have
the difference is that when I was a kid
keeping up with the trend meant wearing
jeans that didn't fit for a brief
strange moment in the 90s it also meant
carrying a yo-yo around in your pocket
and showing off your yo-yo tricks that
was a thing
kids it was a simpler time
now keeping up with the trend means
fundamentally changing your identity
but it is more than just a matter of
trends we're also witnessing I think the
death of personality
people have lost the ability to talk
about their personalities and they're
increasingly losing their ability to
develop Personalities in the first place
LGBT identification and gender
non-conformity are among other things a
replacement for personality
those who claim these identities will
pretend that they're unique and
independent and all of that but in fact
they are fleeing from the unique from
Independence
they seek to label and categorize every
part of themselves with nothing left
over
nothing left of them after they've
claimed all of their letters in the LGBT
alphabet soup
and that's why they all end up looking
the same and sounding the same
and thinking the same way about
everything
it's no wonder that someone like Madonna
has jumped on the trend her life has
been nothing but a series of publicity
stunts
she hasn't had a true human personality
for decades
she doesn't even have a true human face
anymore she has dissolved whatever was
authentic and real within herself and
traded it in for whatever it is that she
is now
but at least she made some money on the
deal
which is more than can be said for most
of the people who are following in her
footsteps
still
I think she is the one who is today
canceled that'll do it for this portion
of the show as we move over to the
members block hope to see you there if
not we'll talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]